un nuevo golpe para la vacuna de oxford
y astrazéneca tres países europeos se
suspendieron temporalmente su uso luego
de que se presentaran casos de trombos
en personas vacunadas dinamarca fue el
primero en anunciar la medida seguido de
noruega e islandia además italia
paralizó el uso de un lote ligado a los
posibles efectos secundarios sumándose a
austria letonia estonia lituania y
luxemburgo por supuesto creo que estoy
tan molesta como todos los demás por
esto y las posibles consecuencias pero
probablemente sea demasiado pronto para
llegar a una conclusión sobre este
asunto cuando existe un riesgo por
supuesto hay que investigarlo el inicio
de esta nueva crisis para la
farmacéutica anglosueca se dio luego de
que austria retirara esta semana una
tanda de dosis de la vacuna mientras
investigaba la muerte por trastornos de
coagulación de una enfermera y una
embolia pulmonar en otra persona
vacunada mientras las autoridades
austríacas aclararon que aún no hay
evidencia que vincula estos hechos con
la vacuna la agencia europea del
medicamento recomendó continuar usándola
porque sus beneficios siguen superando
sus riesgos
países como alemania francia y reino
unido- defendieron su seguridad
estamos muy confiados como resultado de
los rigurosos controles nacionales que
realizamos de que la vacuna es segura
pero por supuesto respetamos al mismo
tiempo que cada país quiera seguir sus
procesos regulatorios con mucho cuidado
a ver que flay esta última piedra en el
camino para astrazéneca se suma a los
cuestionamientos por la demora en la
entrega de vacunas a la unión europea y
las dudas planteadas en algunos países
por la falta de datos sobre su
efectividad en mayores de 65 años